good morning we start with shock new
claims of torture in Ukraine Sky News
has visited towns recently recaptured by
Ukrainian forces near to the Russian
border and has heard claims of how the
occupiers punished residents we also
spoke to one soldier who told us that it
wasn't just the Russian military but
that local police were collaborating
with the occupiers to carry out the
torture our defense and security editor
Deborah Haynes reports now near the
Ukrainian Russia border and a warning
her report Keynes contains descriptions
of alleged torture
Russia's invasion is going backwards in
parts of Ukraine
powerful tank towed off the battlefield
like a plow
it's a very different route from the one
used to enter like this Railway
connecting Russia with Ukraine
nothing running now after Ukrainian
troops recaptured territory right up to
the Border but they've not yet secured
the peace
this sign says that the border with
Russia is in that direction it's about
two and a half miles down the road the
ukrainians have retaken control of the
border crossing point but it's still
coming under direct Russian fire and
we've been told it's too dangerous to
head there at the moment
in the towns and Villages closest to
Russia an eerie quiet in between the
sporadic shelling
there are suspicions not everyone here
in vov chansk is sorry Russia's
occupation has ended
a soldier who's accompanying us is Keen
for the man to answer our questions
[Music]
foreign
it used to be the main police station
until the Russians came I'm outside what
was until just a few days ago a Russian
base here behind me that was a Russian
military checkpoint and on the floor
there are a number of old Russian
newspapers this one here dated the 9th
of August with a headline that rather
fittingly reads Ukraine promises
counter-offensive
the occupiers appeared to have
controlled by fear punishing those
sympathetic to Ukraine
is
this is the site police are
investigating the torture claims so he
weren't allowed inside
foreign
the soldier introduces us to his family
they couldn't see each other during the
occupation making moments like these all
the more precious
the father shows us marks from where he
says he was detained and tortured with
electric shocks but not by the Russians
instead he says it was local policemen
who chose to collaborate with the
occupiers and wanted answers about a
theft
foreign
with the village back under Ukrainian
control those police officers apparently
fled to Russia but the sense of betrayal
lingers
debraham Sky News near the Ukraine
Russia border
Sally Johnny is now from the capital
cave um hi Sally can't even begin to
comprehend as if these poor people
didn't have enough to contend with
neither having to deal with
collaborators
yeah that's right okay it's important to
remember this deep suspicion on both
sides here as Ukrainian forces liberate
areas of the country as we've seen in
the Northeast in the last couple of
weeks they're finding uh civilians
who've been through Unthinkable pain
during five to six months of Russian
occupation but of course there will be
some people who chose not to evacuate
those areas because they're either
pro-russian or at least Russian
sympathizers and certainly president
zielinski in his nightly address warn
those people that they now face a choice
to either flee the country or face the
full force of the law now you Ukrainian
forces are said to have made more
advances in the Northeast overnight
liberating a town just six miles west of
lissy chance K now you may remember back
in July that was a subject of fierce
fighting for weeks so for them to have
got that close to an area in the hansk
in the Eastern donbass region is
significant progress indeed certainly at
a point where many expected there to be
this grinding war of attrition going
into the winter and of course a strong
message from Liz truss today as she goes
into her first international meeting as
prime minister on the world stage over
in New York that the UK's support for
Ukraine will remain unwavering and she's
pledged to give the same amount of
military aid and funding to Ukraine next
year as we did this year which was
estimated to be around 2.3 billion
pounds the UK's contribution second only
to Americas and certainly Ukrainian
forces are trying to make the point that
this military aid and these weapons
being given by International parties
partners are making a huge difference
here okay Sally thank you join now by
the new culture secretary here in the
studio Michelle Donald hi good to see
you good morning 2.3 billion is what Liz
trust is promising again where's that
money coming from with the second
biggest military down and we are
committed to doing that again next year
we'll outline exactly the details of
where that funny is from but we believe
as government is fundamentally important
that we're standing up for democracy
that we're continuing doing to protect
Ukraine in their fight back and that
we're standing up for the rest of the
world who needs to end their Global
dependence on Russia which is one of the
factors behind the increasing price in
fuel so this is actually going to help
the cost of living of people not just in
the UK but across the globe as well and
we hope that other countries will uh
we'll see what we're doing and follow
our example but where's the money coming
from as I said a moment ago okay we will
outline exactly where that money is
coming from but I'm sure that you agree
with me that this is
the chancellors on Friday fiscal event
the fiscal event is on on Friday I'm not
going to preempt exactly what he's going
to say in that event but we'll be
outlining their more support in terms of
cost of living looking at taxation like
we promised during the campaign to
secure Liz trust as prime minister and
all the details will be be coming out on
Friday the reason our bills are so high
is because of the war in Ukraine how
high uh do those bills have to go before
we have to reevaluate our support no no
this isn't about our support this year
this is about saying that we are going
to continue our support next in terms of
the Ukraine if you're talking about
um support for for people in a country
we've already given considerable support
so we put the money into the household
support fund we also gave the money on
council tax but what we've announced as
a government that's only just uh been
imposed for two weeks with this new
prime minister is an energy price
guarantee where we are assuring the
British public that they will get at
least a thousand pounds of their energy
bills had we not acted and that's on top
of the other measures we've taken in the
coming months people will get 400 pounds
of their energy bills irregardless of
their income the most vulnerable in
society will be getting at least 1 200
pounds so you've got to look at the
package in the round there's a great
deal of support that we've been putting
in place we've always been honest that
this winter it's going to be hard and
one of our overarching priorities is to
support people through it whilst also
growing the economy and preventing this
from ever happening again yeah sorry I
didn't explain myself very well my
question is the reason that bills are
going up as high as they are is because
of the situation in Ukraine it's a big
driving Factor yes so how high do our
bills have to go before we re-evaluate
our support in Ukraine well I don't
think that is the case we're not
re-evaluating our support in the Ukraine
what we're saying is we're doubling down
on our support in the UK so how high do
bills have to go it doesn't matter how
high they go what no so we've already
allocated 2.3 billion to support uh
Ukraine in terms of the military effort
where the third uh biggest supporter in
terms of humanitarian effort what we're
saying in this announcement is our
support for next year we're committing
again to support the Ukraine by the same
tune and we're encouraging other
countries around the globe and that's
what the Prime Minister will be doing at
the UN General Assembly to ensure that
we're all working together to support
the Ukraine to help bring those bills
down which also up because of covid as
well as you know yeah what's the Prime
Minister going to be talking to Joe
Biden about given that a trade deal is
not on the table
I can't go into details of exactly what
the Prime Minister will be talking about
in a bilateral meeting but what I can
say is that that will be happening this
week it's a uh it's it's in the diary uh
you UK and the US have enjoyed a very
special relationship over the years we
want to cement that solidify that and
make sure that that relationship is is
completely fostered between both of
those leaders but looking at what let's
trusts our prime minister has said it
doesn't look as though there's a trade
deal on the table well look
um the the Prime Minister and the
president will be meeting this week
they'll be talking about a variety of
different issues including potential
trade deals so let's see what comes out
of that meeting not according to lestrol
she said not well yes so I'm saying
they'll be talking about a range of
different things the purpose of this
meeting is not to secure a trade deal
this is the first bilateral meeting
between the newly elected prime minister
and the president of the United States
talk to me about
um the Queen's funeral how much did it
cost the taxpayer we haven't got that
total figure but I think you know the
taxpayer would argue that it was money
well spent in my own constituency I saw
so many people coming out to celebrate
for the Jubilee across the community and
in dcms the department that I lead we've
been leading on on the efforts around
the queue and that was remarkable and
not just in terms of the amount of
people queue do we know um so over 250
000 went through uh went through
Parliament and we're just crunching the
final numbers that's an approximate
figure at the moment okay but we'll get
back to you with the exact one and it
wasn't just those people it was also the
community that rallied around that you
know we had St John's ambulance sporting
we had this Merit in supporting we had
the Red Cross supporting we have members
of the public coming up with you know
items of cake and food and it was a
great sense of the community coming
together I always think of um of our
late monikers the glue that brought
Society together and communities
together and in her in her final sort of
act that's exactly what she did and it
was remarkable to see that on the ground
having spoken to members in the queue
they've come from afar all over uh for
the the four corners of the nation and
they felt determined and Beyond yeah and
Beyond
so more than 250 000 when will we
ultimately yeah yeah
um when will we know the cost of the
funeral given that we don't know yet uh
no I'm I'm not uh sure of the exact
costings but as I said
um I think the British public you know
would argue that that was money well
spent you saw so many thousands out
there and I don't think anybody could
suggest that our late Monarch didn't
deserve that send-off given the uh the
duty and the the selfless service that
she committed to over 70 years I think
it would be downright Preposterous to
suggest we shouldn't have celebrated her
just asking how much it cost yeah so I
said I don't have that those figures but
we will have it in the fullness of time
so that wouldn't be uh my decision to
take care okay
um talk to me about when you were at um
education I mean you weren't there very
long were you well I was I was there for
over three years yeah as the Secretary
of State how long were you there yeah so
well as you know the answer already okay
it was 36 hours but I was serving in the
cabinet for 10 months and with all that
minister in two different roles so it
was there for over three years okay 17
000 pounds is what you've got apparently
as a payoff as you said you said that
one as well yeah exactly that okay so
you you said that you were going to give
it to a charity no I didn't I said that
if I wasn't able to reject the money I
would give it to a charity but I
rejected it oh okay okay I didn't know
that question okay I'm surprised you
didn't give it to a charity but there
you go well it was tax payers money so I
think it would be wrong for me to take
tax pays money then decide you know
which charity I wanted to give it to so
I was very clear that if I was able to
reject it I would reject it and I did
okay talk to me about the online harm
Bill where are we going with that
um so it's a vital piece of legislation
it was in our Manifesto as we know the
world has changed remarkably and it's it
is important that we prioritize
protecting children having spoken to a
number of parents and and organizations
in this sector you know it is important
that we fill in the gaps in our
legislation and protect children which
is what this bill does so we're going to
get it back to Parliament as soon as
possible finish it off it's been through
most of that for a long time I remember
interviewing the chief exec of ofcom
more than a year ago and it was supposed
to become law last year still waiting
well it's gone through most of the
stages as we've just elected a new prime
minister we've had a period of national
morning we will be bringing it back to
the house as soon as we possibly can it
does require a little bit of work not in
relation to uh protecting Children
online absolutely not we're not changing
any of that but we want to make sure
that we've got the balance right in
terms of free speech in relation to
adults so when will it become law as I
just said as soon as possible we bring
it back to the commons and we do need to
edit that bill so just in the process of
getting that done and then we'll be
bringing it back of course we couldn't
have done this automatically becoming 10
days because we had a period of now yeah
we've had plenty of time before that yes
but I've only been in post two weeks
okay and what I'm saying to you today
what I'm saying to you as I sit here
today is that I'm giving you my cast
iron guarantee that I'm committed to
this it's my number one priority I'm
going to make sure that the bill is
slightly tweaked bring it back to
Parliament as soon as possible because I
completely understand why this is a
vital piece of legislation to protect
Children online do uh big tech companies
do enough to protect our kids
I think that the problem is is that it
can be inconsistent and they are always
held to account on this so the answer is
no which is why we're bringing forward
legislation to ensure that they do uh
when you say a Helter account which ones
in particular hold them to account well
that's why we're bringing forward
this bill is primarily focused uh well
it is focused uh providers that um
generate online content so a lot of that
is is social media providers and we've
got the inquest starting today in the
absolutely tragic case of of Molly
Russell and and we all know that she is
just let's just remind our viewers she's
14 and she she killed herself yeah um as
a result of online harm back in 2017 I
mean are we looking at
um people like Facebook people like
Twitter they need to Instagram they need
of course Facebook they need to be doing
more but they do need to be doing more
which is why we're going to legislate to
ensure that they do so that we have
um the not only the legal powers to do
so but also we can then whack them with
massive massive Vines which then is a
big deterrent and ensures that they act
in a responsible way from the off
will you abolish the BBC license fee so
I've only been in the post two weeks but
what I can say is over the last few days
the BBC did a tremendous job as did Skye
in covering a very poignant moment in
British history as we celebrated the
life of our late Monarch but it's it is
no secret that I have been a long-term
skeptic of the license fee and that we
need to make sure that the BBC is
sustainable in the long term so I'm
looking at this in the round I'm
somebody that listens I'm somebody that
decides policy based on evidence and
that's what I will be doing over the
coming weeks yeah you pointed out that
although you were only at in post two
weeks you've been in government for many
years I'm sure that the BBC license fee
has come up on on occasion
um do you think it's time for it to be
scrapped I think we need to make sure
that the BBC is sustainable in the long
term
already said what does that actually
mean well it means that in an age when
you have Netflix you have Amazon Prime
you have all of these other
subscription-based uh channels then it
does throw into question whether the
current model that the BBC uses is
actually sustainable in the long term
and is providing that choice element to
the general public but as I said you
know I'm somebody that listens I make
decisions based on evidence that's what
I will be doing over the coming weeks
I'm not going to make policy on the hoof
I don't think that's the right approach
when we're looking at these big policy
decisions okay good to talk to you
thanks for taking the time to join us
thank you very much indeed thank you
looking at the front pages for you this
morning most of them leading with the
Queen's funeral the guardian shows the
coffin with the headline the final
farewell
that same picture is on the front of the
mirror with the words until we meet
again
and the express also carries the image
and says simply God Rest Our Queen
the Ft shows King Charles and other
members of the royal family following
the coffin out of Westminster Abbey
on the front of the Metro we see a
full-page picture of the funeral Cottage
making its way to Windsor
and the procession moving down the long
walk outside Windsor Castle is on the
front of the Sun newspaper
while the times has a photo of the
coffin being carried into Saint George's
Chapel
still to come on the program for you
this morning as we hear fresh
allegations of torture in Russian
occupied areas of Ukraine we'll speak to
a former UK ambassador to Ukraine that's
Lee Turner
with the government preparing to deliver
its plans to tackle the fuel crisis this
Friday at eight o'clock I'll speak to
Labor's Shadow Financial secretary to
the treasury James Murray
and with millions of disabled people to
start receiving 150 pounds payment to
help with the cost of living today
speaking to the director of
communications advocacy and activism at
the charity mencap as they question
whether it will be enough
well from today it's just saying about 6
million people with disabilities will
start to receive that one-off payment of
150 pounds to help with the cost of
living crisis but campaigners and some
of those receiving the money have told
us doesn't scratch the surface he's
Aisha
Katie is a full-time carer for her
husband Mark he suffers from a rare form
of motor neuron disease most of the
equipment and care he needs to stay
alive runs off electricity it means as a
household their expenses are higher than
ever and still Rising as a disabled
family you need more energy to keep your
home
warmer so that a person doesn't get
chest infections for example might be
that you need extra fridge space to hold
drugs you might be
using an electric wheelchair and having
to power that so it's it's things that
we can't cut back on it's not like we
can just throw on an extra jumper
Katie's husband is one of six million
people who will receive a one-off
disability cost of living payment of 150
pounds but she says it's not going to be
enough at the 150 pounds won't really
scratch the surface I'm really worried
that that's going to go in an instance
and I'm bearing my head a bit in the
sand at the moment thinking about you
know how long that will last this worry
will be shared by many people living
with disabilities concern around the
support on offer is widespread at the
very least we believe that disability
payment of 150 pounds needs to be
doubled we know that disabled household
holds a struggling we know that 150
pounds has gone nowhere near the sides
of the amount of money and financial
shocks that disabled households are
facing so at a minimum we want to see
that doubled in response a government
spokesperson said in addition to this
one-off payments we will continue to
provide a strong financial support
system for people with disabilities and
their carers including personal
Independence payment Universal Credit
and carers allowance for the millions
affected
extra costs these families are now
facing are unavoidable what they so
urgently need is more help not to fund
luxuries but to access basic necessities
Aisha zahid Sky News
and I'm going to be speaking to the
director of communications advocacy and
activism as I said at a learning
disability charity mencap that's Jackie
O'Sullivan a little later on in the
program looking at some of today's other
headlines for you though now and Joe
Biden has arrived back in Washington
following the Queen's funeral he'll join
dozens of world leaders including the
Prime Minister when they address the
United Nations General Assembly the US
president and Liz truss have a bilateral
meeting scheduled for tomorrow there's
Liz truss's first foreign trip as prime
minister on the plane when asked about
trade deals she told us there aren't any
negotiations currently taking place with
the US and none are expected to start
anytime soon
five people have been killed during
violent protests in Iran over the death
of a young woman while she was detained
for allegedly violating strict hijab
rules police said 22 year old Marcia
amini had a heart attack and was taken
to hospital while waiting with others
held by the morality police but her
father has accused the police of being
responsible for her death
eight years after his case came to
Global attention through the serial
podcast a judge in the United States has
quashed the murder conviction of Adan
Saeed he was 17 years old when he was
sentenced to life in prison in the year
2000 for the murder of his girlfriend
hey Min Lee here's Martha Kellner
[Applause]
he's the man whose case spawned a wave
of True Crime as entertainment now admin
Syed is leaving prison his conviction
quashed the 41 year old has spent 23
years behind bars for the murder of his
ex-girlfriend hymin Lee but prosecutors
say a new investigation has pinpointed
two other suspects Syed supporters are
delighted I spent 20 years with Adnan
he's a very good friend of mine I love
him to death it was like a weight lifted
off my shoulders to see him released and
free today knowing that he was innocent
the whole time he's an impeccable human
being
um
a wonderful person and hopefully the
world will get to see that real soon
the hit podcast serial breathed new life
into science defense nine years ago it
cast out on his conviction transformed
the True Crime genre and changed how
many viewed the justice system Chicago
it's cereal one story told week by week
I'm Sarah Koenig 18 year old high Min
Lee's body was found discarded in a park
her family say they were blindsided by
the decision to quash said's conviction
my clients all they wanted was
information they want the truth to come
out if the truth is that somebody else
killed their sister daughter they want
to know that more than anybody they were
shut out of the legal process by the
court and the State's Attorney's office
and there was it was inexcusable the
violation of Maryland law and our my
clients are exploring their options with
regard to Appeals
Society is now under house arrest he's
not yet been declared innocent
prosecutors have 30 days to decide
whether to retry him their next step and
his will once again be firmly in the
media glare Master Kelner Sky News
the queen has been buried beside her
husband Prince Philip after a state
funeral an appointed Chapel Service as
the nation bid a final farewell to
Britain's longest reigning monarch the
government has told this program in the
last few moments that more than 250 000
people came to see the queen lying in
state
and late last night the royal family
issued a previously unseen photograph of
her majesty the image shows the lake
Queen on holiday in Balmoral back in
1971 it was published along with a
caption from Shakespeare's Hamlet which
simply says May flights of Angels Sing
thee to thy rest what an amazing
photograph
well it followed an emotional day for
grieving members of the royal family
with hundreds of thousands of people
lining the streets to catch a glimpse of
the procession carrying the Queen's
coffin our national correspondent Tom
Parmenter reports
the Elizabethan era ended here
in Royal Windsor
[Music]
the Final Act of a farewell that matched
the magnitude of her Reign it is not in
vain they watched in their tens of
thousands in Hyde Park absorbing every
detail
and what this moment of change means to
them Charles has got uh some big shoes
to step into so Sophie does it and um
you know makes us all feel good about
our country he's been out to the crowds
and people might have a certain opinion
of him but I think he's probably changed
a lot of opinions in the last few days
they've got a place in our hearts that
cannot be replaced by anything else you
know we are a monarchy you know when you
know we are her subjects and we'll
become the subjects of you know King
Charles uh and then of a of King William
clearing this Festival of remembrance
was quick the Vivid memories will remain
but life never stands still especially
for a new king the sympathy and the
support that have ruled the first days
of his reign will in time give way to
scrutiny about the cost of all this when
some can't afford to eat and the unity
of the United Kingdom as well as the
Commonwealth
[Music]
there is the Family itself the king is
known to favor a slimmed down monarchy
one that offers better value for money I
think a lot of people are very much like
the royal family and the whole royalty
because of the queen because she is all
our grandmothers in theory
um how the transition is going to go I
don't know in many ways he's been ahead
of his time in conservation
architecture and other other events so I
think he will be extremely good King
such a difficult time where people are
really struggling in so many different
ways financially you know there's so
much going on in the world that they
can't be completely removed from that
because I think then that people
disengage with them the crowds will be
back for the coronation at some point
next year
but the evolution of this most British
institution is already underway
Tom Parmenter Sky News
well official morning following the
death of the queen will come to an end
this morning flags on public buildings
will return to full Mass 12 days after
she died our Royal correspondent Laura
bundock is with us now from Windsor the
royal family still in morning uh good
morning to you
thank you
okay yes that's right Windsor waking up
here after witnessing the most
incredibly historic day the queen buried
here later rest finally alongside the
Duke of Edinburgh and that very private
burial just her family present and the
release of that quite moving photo of
her at Balmoral in 1971 with the quote
from Hamlet used by the king at
Westminster Hall last week May flights
of Angels Sing thee to thy rest and yes
the period of national morning now over
but for the royal family for household
staff it continues in terms of what this
means well it means we won't see the
royal family out and about there will be
no engagements and flags will be flying
at half-mast at Royal residences like
here at Windsor and I think we can all
understand and appreciate that perhaps
after that really public State funeral
and an incredibly busy week especially
for the king the family will need and
want this quiet time for their own
private grief
but yeah indeed so and I saw the image
of the king yesterday as the national
anthem or sung I mean he is the king he
does have to take part in a public
morning but also he's a man who's lost
his mother
he is and he has been working through
the grief hasn't he but I think in the
statement he released he was obviously
very much comforted by the messages of
support he said that him and the queen
consulate were both deeply touched by
the amount of condolence messages they'd
received and when it came to this
incredibly busy tour of all the nations
we saw him in Scotland then in Northern
Ireland and in Wales at the end of last
week he said he was moved beyond measure
by the numbers of people who had come
out to pay tribute to his mother to the
queen but also to welcome him as king So
for him this strange situation of having
to lead the nation's grief and Lead his
family's grief while he himself is
obviously bereft and mourning to
okay thank you thanks very much
president of Brazil bolsonaro has caused
controversy by using his trip to the UK
for the Queen's funeral to do some
election campaigning in London comparing
the price of fuel to how much it costs
in Brazil
I'm here in London England and the price
of petrol is one pound 61. this is
approximately nine real 60 a liter
practically double the average of many
Brazilian States our gasoline is in fact
one of the cheapest in the world last
night
okay um so that's what he was saying
while he was in London we all know how
much it cost don't we for a liter of
fuel um here let's find out what the
weather's going to be doing this morning
shall we
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
rather cloudy mostly dry a few showery
outbreaks for you are possible
foreign
sponsored by Qatar Airways
um so look at what's happening as far as
the climate dashboard is concerned yep
we have brought it back using a lot more
coal today than we normally do 4.2
percent of our real-time power mix is
coal a lot of gas as well it has been
chillier hasn't it over the last couple
of days uh I don't really need to talk
you through this do I'll do it once um
there you go global warming since 1880
up 1.25 degrees that's an incredibly
important number we don't want it to get
to 1.5 as we know and this is the total
carbon dioxide emissions in millions of
tons that according to the University of
Oxford
um nuclear
14.3 percent
officials the Importer Rico say the
country is experiencing what they have
called historic flooding caused by
Hurricane Fiona most of the Caribbean
island is without power and water and
two people are believed to have died
forecasters say more than 15 inches of
rain has fallen in the last three days
and have won the hurricane could strike
the Dominican Republic
and more than 130 000 homes are still
without power in Japan after after
typhoon nanmadol swept across the
country on Sunday morning two people
known to have died in at least 87
injured after the tropical storm brought
torrential winds and flooded streets in
the southwest of the country
after the break speaking to Lee Turner
the former UK permanent representative
to the UN and former ambassador to
Ukraine that's come in just a few
moments time
[Music]
again everybody very good morning to you
Alias here as you can see
um we're just hearing that 250 000
people paid their respects as the queen
was lying in the State Department of
culture media and sport of course in
charge of of events and um the secretary
of state was with us a short time ago
also talking about the Prime Minister
being in New York at the moment yeah
that's right so the Prime Minister
obviously politics has been paused but
it is straight back to business today
she's in New York for the UN General
Assembly and the most interesting
um part of what she was telling
reporters on the plane overnight to New
York was about this trade deal with the
US this has obviously been talked about
a lot
um but there we've long thought that the
the plan for it to happen by the end of
this year wasn't going to happen it was
it was going to be delayed again and
again and she has basically said that
um it's it's a long way off she said I
don't have an expectation that U.S
negotiations are going to start in the
short to medium her and that was Liz
truss speaking on the plane overnight
Michelle Donald wasn't really directly
answering your questions about that this
morning she said that we have a special
relationship with the us but I think the
implication from Liz truss is that we're
going to focus our efforts eastwards on
things like the trade deal with India
but for those who'd been hoping for a
trade deal with the US this obviously
isn't good news yeah I mean there were
more swerves than a box set of Top Gear
from her this morning
um talk to me about what she was saying
about about the BBC license fee yes I
think everyone knows that Michelle
donalan is a a skeptic of the BBC
license fee we know of course that in
January the license fee deal was settled
it's been frozen for two years but um
she I think in terms of the longer term
picture for the BBC license fee
um was making clear that maybe things
would have to be rethought she basically
said that it's no secret that the
license fee that she's a skeptic she
says the license fee needs to be to see
if it's sustainable in the long term
talking about subscription Services
saying that it needs to look at whether
it needs to change to keep Pace with
that we know that the conservative
government have been looking at this has
been plenty of people who've been
worried about whether the BBC license
fee could have to change altogether be
cut and I think she's made clear that
something she is going to be looking at
um Alice take at nine o'clock yeah
looking forward to it thank you very
much Stephen thanks a lot and returning
now to Ukraine and Sky News has visited
areas of the country reclaimed from
Russian control where locals have told
us about suffering torture at the hands
of police collaborating with the
occupying forces and in his nightly
address president zielinski had this
warning for those collaborating with the
Russian military
I don't have that just at the moment I
can tell you that he's told them if they
have fled to Russia not to come back or
face the consequences join now by former
UK permanent representative to the UN in
Vienna and uh also former UK ambassador
to Ukraine that's Lee Turner hello to Mr
Turner thank you for joining us on the
program this morning as if the poor
people of Ukraine did not have enough to
deal with we're now hearing about police
collaborating with the Enemy
it's it's a very Grim picture that we're
getting out of these formerly occupied
areas of North Eastern Ukraine we've
seen this already a few months ago when
Ukraine was able to reoccupy areas in
the west of the country that had been
seized by Russia right at the beginning
of this Invasion where we saw all kinds
of evidence of Human Rights atrocities
and war crimes now we're seeing very
much the same picture in the northeast
of the country in the heart cave region
where there are mass Graves that people
are exhuming literally hundred hundreds
of bodies that have been buried in the
woods these are scenes very much
reminiscent of World War II war crimes
and we're just waiting to learn more
about those deaths how they came about
whether this evidence does constitute
war crimes and it's very important that
these allegations be investigated
thoroughly and that those responsible
should be brought to Justice
and former Ambassador history tells us
does it not that where there is uh one
Mass burial site there are likely to be
many others
unfortunately we don't yet know the
scale of this these are Big areas that
have been recovered by the Ukrainian
Armed Forces they've had a really good
run over the last Fortnight or so and
have reoccupied several
key towns and cities which are very
important to the Russian occupying
forces for keeping their forces in the
east of the country supplied so that's
that's kind of good news that the
ukrainians have had some Battlefield
successes on the other hand it does mean
that they're uncovering all kinds of
evidence of what has happened during the
Russian occupation and that looks very
Grim this story of collaboration is of
course another difficult aspect of this
if you imagine if if the city or or town
that you were living in was occupied by
a foreign government and you had a
choice between whether to work with
those occupying forces or to resist and
face death or torture what would you do
and clearly for many people in Ukraine
they've had to make very difficult
decisions and that leaves those
collaborators those who did
collaboration a very difficult position
now that Ukraine is back
um United Nations General Assembly um
often seen by many as a talking shop but
they are going to be a focusing we here
on Ukraine today
um and tomorrow uh what are you
expecting
well you're right that many of the
speeches that are made at the U.N
General Assembly over the next few days
will be listened to by almost no one at
all so the the world leaders will get up
on the big stage in the uh in the main
General Assembly will make their
speeches
um the value of that can be debated but
away from that main scene there will be
a host of bilateral meetings of caucuses
people meeting to discuss amongst other
things and perhaps primarily Ukraine and
what's really important is that the
Ukrainian successes of the last
Fortnight have changed the mood
internationally what that means is that
the most difficult thing for the UK and
the US and others who support Ukraine
has been to maintain Western unity in
terms of supporting Ukraine providing
military assistance
maintaining sanctions that's always been
a tough ask when the conflict was frozen
and not much was happening but now that
Ukraine has scored some successes and
it's been shown that Russia's grip on
the occupied areas of Ukraine is can be
broken that has changed the mood so it's
easier to maintain that unity and on the
other side
Russia itself is facing increased
diplomatic pressure we've seen those
meetings between President Putin and ji
of China and Modi of India where there
seem to have been criticisms made by
China and India of Russia's policies
that's a that's a first since February
that changes the mood and then we've
also seen Russia fire one of its main
weapons which is to cut off the gas to
Western Europe and in fact since that
happened gas prices have gone down and
Russian income from energy sales has
gone down and the Russian economy is in
more trouble so all of those things
strengthen the hand of Ukraine and its
supporters and appear to weaken Russia
although the war's not over yet
I was speaking to a very uh senior
military man uh former military man I
should say
um here in the UK and he was saying that
he feels that there's a 30 to 40 percent
chance that the war in Ukraine could be
over by Christmas what do you think
well it's a Fool's game if you ask me
predicting what's going to happen in
this War I remember being asked this
very same question back in February and
um saying it was very difficult to
foresee how this would how this would go
this war at the time everybody thought
that Russia would win very easily but
the recent War actually two years ago
between Azerbaijan and Armenia showed
that Modern Warfare had become very much
more unpredictable than it had been in
the past and so we have seen with the
war between Russia and Ukraine Russia
has really taken a hiding first in the
west of the country now in the east of
the country against everybody's
expectations I would like to hope that
the momentum is with Ukraine and that we
might see further collapses of Russian
forces over the days and weeks ahead
that would be great if that happens on
the other hand it's quite unpredictable
and Russia still has considerable forces
in the east of Ukraine we don't know
quite what they're capable of but let's
hope that your military source is
correct
okay good to do it indeed so uh good to
talk to you thank you very much indeed
for joining us for my UK permanent
representative to the UN in Vienna thank
you
coming up is the prime minister of ours
to lift the ban on fracking in England
everybody hearing from a professor in
carbon capture about the risks involved
that to come in just a second
[Music]
now listross has announced the ban on
fracking will be lifted as part of plans
to accelerate the UK's domestic energy
Supply it was banned in England in 2019
after new research raised fresh fears
over the risk of earthquakes join now by
Stuart Hazeldean professor of carbon
capture at the University of Edinburgh
hello to Professor thank you for joining
us on the program this morning
um your thoughts on the decision by the
new prime minister
oh well I think obviously the
government's entitled to do what they do
but I think anybody trying to venture
into this drilling for onshore uh Shale
gas or Shale oil is taking a huge
commercial risk because you have to ask
three questions is there a resource
there how are we going to get it out and
what's the effect on climate and it's
clear that the initial estimates by the
British geologic survey were very very
optimistic maybe a hundred years of
resource there but then subsequent
Drilling and then particularly
laboratory analysis from the Rocks
recovered from that drilling shows that
there's very very little oil and gas
remaining in those rocks it has been
generated long long ago in the geologic
past but it's leaked away and so there's
no resource there in the vast majority
of the UK there's perhaps just one or
two pockets but there's nothing like the
resource originally proposed there's
just maybe a few patches in East
Yorkshire and then so there's a huge
commercial risk of drilling very
expensive holes to deep depth and
finding nothing and a lot of people have
lost a lot of money already on uh failed
drilling for uh for Shale gas in the UK
we also know that the government made
the conservative government in 2019 made
a pledge to stop Drilling and fracking
because there was an uncertain method of
no clear method of predicting any
earthquakes and the recent report from
the British Geological Survey leaked out
in the newspaper a few days ago shows
that there is indeed no progress been
made on that so there's no scientific
basis no evidence basis to make a better
prediction of earthquakes so we can go
companies can go Drilling and they'll be
liable for any earthquake effects on
their boreholes or on surrounding
property
and then thirdly how are you going to
get this out yeah yeah I was going to
ask you about the impact on the
environment
yeah so there's this needs very
specialist drilling Crews which we don't
have many many in the UK mostly these
this is an American operation so any
extensive campaign will need to bring in
people from outside and to be
commercially viable and significant this
needs something like a hundred boreholes
a year being drilled for a 10-year
period and that's a huge campaign and
none of these sites at the moment have
planning permission remaining from the
local councils they may get licensing
permission from central government but
that's very different to getting
permission to constructive sites likes
being shown on the screen at the moment
to consent all the truck movements all
the pipelines necessary to deliver water
or take away any Wastewater and then
lastly on this uh fracking also injects
lots and lots of water into the ground
to break apart the rock under really
high pressure but when the water comes
back to the surface it's very very salty
it's contaminated with heavy metal
chemicals in that and sometimes even
with natural radioactivity and that
needs treatment and purification before
releasing that water back into the
environment and the UK has no
significant facilities to do that so
there are huge problems there
practically and lastly of course is the
effect on climate that introducing any
extra methane production is the opposite
of what the intergovernment panel on
climate change say the opposite of what
the International Energy agency say and
the opposite of what the committee on
climate change say so this is a strange
and potentially full Hardy Venture for
any commercial operators okay it's great
to talk to you thank you for taking the
time to join us we'll let you get on
your way thank you thank you
craters have been discovered on Mars
after scientists were able to track
shock waves caused by Space Rock
[Music]
S I think so Jeff Wayne
these spots on the so-called red planet
are the first craters ever traced from
listening to the impact of meteoroids
hitting another planet NASA's inside
Lander which touched down on Mars nearly
four years ago was able to record and
send back the seismic waves if you've
never heard War of the Worlds Jeff Wayne
War of the Worlds you should definitely
listen to it in the car later on today
it's fantastic